what is going on there reject Nation Greg John
and look who's back after missing episode three
just the worst person we need a white Savior for
a Miss Marvel showing what you're him and I know
what I know what I'm ready guys we're gonna watch
Miss Marvel episode 4 today and we got of course
got koi genre joining us again follow him on Tick
Tock where he does plenty of like 60 seconds to
three minute breakdowns of a bunch of Marvel is
this if you like Marvel go follow him there all
right comps in general always asking me to plug
it and I'm like shut up boy I've actually I'm
just like come here on my little elbow I see those
million Tick Tock subscribers so I'm relevant guys
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated as
soon as they also subscribe to John I think they
should also subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when the next Miss Marvel's
up also uh full-length watch along three sync
up with the time code available for our super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page over there
I cover plenty of shows we're at the same tier we
have some shows we're exclusively reaction
highlights and watch Longs include did and
lastly thinking of them prepper boys for helping
us edit down these highlights let's get to it
you both need to come to Karachi
still waiting for when they do the
traditional Marvel the the swelling
yeah however I love the needle drops they
do I've been really good in the show yeah
if it's not connected to the MCU I don't
care about anything in this world what are
what are songs they created Pakistan for the
comics right these mics are the death of us
it was a really good through glass
the comologists get on a plane foreign
because your Nani is very old and she insisted
on us coming to Pakistan I think that we need
to call a temporary truce I don't know I
thought you got on the plane by herself
whatever it is that you've been up to lately
the National Airport
Naki is upset why are friends
in these superhero shows always
upset when they find out that their
friends is super gonna be so excited
children yes you are taller than I remember you
are still really foolish burn middle of the night
you should be sleeping oh come on I'm just coming
from a party yeah Grandma hi Mommy attention
welcome home thank you it's good to be here
your skin is so dry oh no spoken like a mother
I like that it's not all in New York that's
nice yeah yeah look at us venturing oh
the pita look delicious yeah multiverses
have done great things for opening titles
a dog too Pita dog
no
holy crap what a fancy ass we're gonna give
someone I had no idea you could draw we lost so
much during partition beautiful looks like when
she first put on the Bengal this is Miami Aisha
your great grandmother what I
could remember of her at least
about that we've met have you heard
of gins why did you send this to me
am I a June of course at least
that is what my father told me
actual about this I I don't see what the whole
verse is about it's just genetics I feel like
I'm trying to piece together 100 different things
and I just I'm breaking more than I can fix if you
have lived like I have to learn to find beauty in
the pieces I like this old lady give her powers
the show is so well cast the family feels like
family it's so comfortable yeah I feel like Coy's
Boston family yeah definitely Boston basically
stand-ins for you guys I mean I'm that sloth
let's rock a raccoon guys who's right oh sorry
I didn't realize you were in here with someone
napping pillow come on get up we have the whole
afternoon plan lunch at the board Club is in
one hour it's really examining that is this a
pillow we're here to visit the point is to visit
so let's go come on how do you monetize
this trip oh there are plenty of ways
policy this outfit plays a lot better in Jersey
not a typical Pakistani name it's not I mean well
that's quite my neighbor though she always was a
bitter forever this is where some of karachi's
oldest residents live I like Florida the old
town is where many of the refugees first settled
when they came from India so not like Florida
although it'd be funny if there was a Karachi man
the same way there's a Florida man
always fighting alligators foreign
condescending cousin you know it's like the
first ever Gateway where Nani entered the
country uh well we're going meet us after stay
safe I guess wow excellent they care about their
cousin neglectful it's yours if you tell me the
direction to the train station training station um
yeah I left oh no one more left and
then right little little bit right
a little bit right
surprisingly very accurate directions
it was a little bit right it was just
a little bit that makes the difference
okay now she's a Superhero now you don't
draw attention to yourself matches her
blue and yellow shirt Choice
where'd Kamala go who knows oh
bringing in red dagger found you not
sure what's worse those glasses you
try on with that mask are you I sensed
the newer yeah buddy oh he was prepared
Paco to all my family can have superpowers well
oh my God you're destroying this historic train
station people probably be
nicer if you're a Canadian
superhero Landing with purpose you're
not a clandestine but you have the bangle
how did you get in from Aisha
how do you know about Aisha
getting always wanted to say that but really
we should go there's so many you need to meet
she meets all the greatest guys doesn't she
just well sorry trustworthy dude best boys
Chinese restaurant but this isn't
China whoa whoa how does that work
you ordered ahead that's some fourth one yeah
foreign
this looks way nicer than the restaurant
yeah it's like the Ancient Temple behind the
Papa John's and Uncharted very important have
that Papa John's historic apparels they're gonna
pay Mark Wahlberg but for a descendant of Aisha
I'm sure we can make an exception
how did you know my name is Waleed
your great-grandmother's story is of Legend when
you're ready we have much to discuss I could look
like him one day oh easily yeah like two weeks so
red that's the color it's supposed to be did you
American find a way to whitewash the Chinese food
too yes sir the clandestines are not like the Gin
you've heard about stories on religious texts
so what are they and what am I I'll show you
what are you guys talking
about very videos coming soon
it looks familiar The Veil The
clandestines even your powers
are made of it if the clandestines
use the bangle to tear down the Bell
they'll unleash their world onto us until
there's nothing left of it oh God again
all right guys I was trying to conquer the world
we're mining more problems it says what
you seek is seeking you Captain Marvel
oh wow
nice how is he he'll be okay oh
let's go
this group man having fun let him go
he's not coming with us what she made his choice
but mama oh he has to live with it he just got you
out let me oh it's actually kind of sad when
he says it he looks like such a child there
no oh poor guy I'm still trying to figure out who
I am do you think you're ever gonna figure it out
watch The Rush
your name is minced meat no it's it's chemo
short for Karim we all go by nicknames here
right yeah what's yours uh sloth baby sloth baby
call her sloth baby it's not baby cool name thank
you thank you at least someone appreciates it
all right you ready for the best meal of your
life very different vibe when his hair is down
the Thorp mayor didn't recognize him until now
she just asked me if it was spicy she's
gonna [__] her pants she's gonna die
excited
oh my God the chemistry she forms to all
these guys except for Brian Bruno and Brian
Brandon Ryan Brandon Brandon Bob Barry I know
what did he call him we call him Brian Brian
I got the joke right you just didn't get it I just
didn't get a job jokes are the best we have to
explain everyone knows you like them as a child so
I just kept them around just in case you came back
I may have eaten most of them along the way it
sounds like an excuse to be a hoarder this is
an intervention and even after Baba left you you
continued to cling to these fantastic theories
just thought I'd share them with you I didn't
need your stories mummy I needed my mother
damn good actress man how vibrant
everything is the walls the sheets
everything are awesome you know I was
really depressing scene and you were
just focusing ones I feel so happy see
now she's happy again like the colors
sit sit have a toffee oh it's 20 years old
we believe your genetics could be the answer
to why it is that you can shape the new head
fear is the mind killer
you should know but his history
in every thread of this fabric
so you always remember where you came from
this is starting to look familiar am I a
red dagger now it suits you
ah crap they got there fast
oh [__] this guy can fight
wow yeah I like this guy
oh no
hey go get in quick oh yes yes
live for these action scenes
no it's like T2 in Jurassic Park
references in here I can't go any faster
don't work dang
oh Jesus no kill them there'll be cowards Marvel
ramp awesome
and then it just explodes the whole block explodes
Easter eggs everyone's looking for my voice
is that practical holy crap
oh goody
this house is empty come on
they just follow like animals on them
that's all it takes okay that's the move
okay one guy then
driving on the opposite side of the road
yeah buddy
this poor guy yeah get out of there
guy I want this oh all that money
murder
we have to go aren't you better off in
the truck probably okay he should drive
oh please jump to another Roof oh
come on parkour yes oh no
oh there you go oh yeah
critical moments no
no no no oh yeah no no it's too late he's
gone we have to go I like to I thought that
explosion would be worse yeah it's just
a little sprayed a lot of liquid around
cool beans
nice oh not bad man
oh
you know she's turning into a hell of a fighter
the clothes
oh so this guy just straight up killed just
murdering American people left and right
oh oh
oh dang cheat in the past yeah
she is she's at the partition
so this isn't just some like Vision
she's having she's like there it's
like it feels like people are like avoiding her
foreign
actually seemed to be touching her yeah
yeah like she's in a physical space
wow those look like real ass extras they got yeah
this looks like like one of
those shots from an old movie
um but no I I actually uh I'm I'm really into
that stuff and I and there's something that
doesn't feel sometimes I think the explanation I
feel like you probably generate a lot from those
moments when they're like clandestines fails
and all that jazz yeah they're just like yes
information absorption how is this connecting to
the thing that I think it might be a mythology
from the comic books okay yeah see after you like
eat that up and for me I those scenes are are just
not as compelling are you not as invested
in the mythology in General on the show or
just the expositions or like do you prefer like
are does it feel Exposition dumpy to you since
you're not as invested uh I guess the show's not
really investing me into the exposition okay of
some of those scenes is this usually something
in a Marvel property that is less I usually
I can get I usually like the balance of both I
usually enjoy I can get on board for when I was
someone who hears Exposition and goes Exposition
screw that you know there are other people like
that uh it all just depends to me on it I guess
because I'm So Into the other stuff yeah that
um it's it's weird like I think I like the
action and I don't mind the information I
don't want it to sound like I don't like I'm
just not I just don't find that's I guess like
this show has two things about it right it has
you know Kamala Khan discovering the roots of
her family the relationships there and you know
her place in this world as just like a Pakistani
American girl you know right like that's what
that's like the one show and then the other
show is the Bengal and and clandestines and all
these things and I I actually like the former
um the most and the show definitely leads with
that like you prefer the midst of the Marvel
yeah yeah and I feel like the Marvel part will
probably be most intriguing by the time you see
her like crossing over but don't get me wrong
I think the action is actually weirdly from the
trailers and stuff I thought the action might
be the thing that is not that great about this
series but between last episode and this episode
The Action can genuinely surprise me a lot of the
time like I have really more practical than I
expected definitely I think the the chasing um
was pretty cool it was a lot more stunt work than
I was expecting and they they just utilized a lot
more that was like a [__] that's like 15 minutes
the episode went by because that like that mid
piece was so much longer than I realized because
suddenly we were like oh we're in the third Act
of the show yeah I also felt like it was uh uh
really well choreographed for how much was going
on like I there was more color than normal because
it wasn't just in New York and I could still tell
what was going on at all times like it was really
well framed and the action never got jumpy like
I was with them yeah I completely agree and uh I
mean don't come around I I like parts of the when
the I guess when the X when the battery was so
much would justify my freaking opinion about right
why do you not like something Greg hates motion
especially it's when it feels I like the mystery
part of the uncovering what's going on the mystery
that that mysterious hook always gets me like like
at the end with the you know being put in the
partition and that part is like oh that's really
fascinating we haven't quite seen it done that
way because we've seen a lot of things especially
or just like they go into the past but it's just
like a vision that I'm able to walk through but it
looks like she really somehow she's on that train
transplanted there which is so bizarre um but I I
like the episode overall I'm not but I mean I know
you love ranking stuff I probably say is like my
third favorite uh I don't know I don't really
care I liked it all right I don't care break
it yeah it's good it's a good episode it's fine I
think my one thing that I really respect about it
for sure is that um I'll let you guys just talk
away you know another thing I really respect
about it for sure is you know like we were talking
between recording here especially is that you got
a very specific kind of vibe when they're in New
Jersey and oh my God forgive me everyone what is
this place called kamachi Karachi karachi's so
sorry so sorry to all you guys who are offended
by that but uh Karachi not not for our actual uh
Indian viewers it's like noon or whatever there
yeah so um and we got a good amount of you guys
and um yeah so I I like the way how they really
capture the vibe there like this show seems
to be uh the direction seems to do such a good
job at capturing the vibe of whatever City it's
inhabiting the environment is what I'm getting at
and I really like how it it felt like a different
show but the same show and I really think that's
cool how much they you get a chance to to live in
the environments and really see the cool culture
a lot more through that way in a way that doesn't
seem like they go expositional about it they just
let you like live there and I think that's great
and I like how the tone does affect the series
so I I quite quite enjoy John what you think
about red dagger does good good intro set you up
it was the last thing I expected that was like oh
sorry I was like you've dig deep into my reserves
I thought I was thinking about a pattern opinion
and then of course that stuff red dagger it was
cool to me red dagger I got confused at first
I was like wait a minute okay is one of the
clandestine attacking her okay wait no okay this
is a different guy and uh and yeah I I thought he
was quite Charming we don't really get to spend
much character time with him but uh he's got long
hair like you I know I like him automatically
I mean yeah I liked him I liked their friend
like you know the little group of friends that
they wound up you know eating with after all the
chaos was done I liked the introduction of his
fight style and I liked um I I cannot remember
the name of the guy who's like the mentor who
he's well lead there you go was it well yeah
yeah something like that I think so close yeah and
I like the the interplay of the two of them and
I like seeing them in action I mean I'm looking
forward to learning more about that character as a
character character and I mean this one of all
of them maybe had the most juggling to do in
terms of like you know I could watch that scene
of them like bonding around the fire for a little
bit longer or something like that but yeah for
him as a character other than just like cool you
know show me more um but yeah I like the expander
is that a koi you could Enlighten us on this is
that a koi is red dagger a singular character that
they have now turned into a Consortium or like an
organization or or is it always an organization so
I don't it's funny I was thinking that during the
episode I don't remember being an organization
I remember the character because I and it's in
Jersey City when if memory serves when you meet
him he's in her City uh and I don't know that we
meet others but it's honestly the earlier Arc of
the comics that puts it like seven or eight years
ago um but I really really love that they were
able to capture his physicality in the exact way
I pictured it like some of the wall running and
some of the use of the elongated scarf and all
of those things feel just like the comic book uh
it's also I showed Greg the frame from one of my
favorite issues I think it's issue 8 or 28 I can't
remember the number before the game but uh it's
one of the earlier I don't even remember him doing
that uh but I showed you but like they captured
like the suit so well and like the the chemistry
between the two of them and the fact that like his
costume translates directly from page to screen
is really rad because it feels like physically
how I imagined him so I can kind of put myself
back in reading the comic book to see which story
elements they're going to take because I don't
remember him in this environment so I'm really
curious how that translates to the Jersey City
stuff that I do remember his name is Walid it is
coming way late thanks for telling us goes right
five minutes later oh what's that position called
on podcasts and this on the engineer here to to
to clarify the guy in the chair the red dagger in
the comics is just one guy I thought so yeah and
uh cream is a Jersey City if memory serves and
they meet uh one of those like uh superhero meat
cute so they find a little first then they realize
they're on the same side the the reveal like this
it's adorable there they go adorable so uh who do
you think she's gonna end up going within the show
because she seemed quite into um umron Kareem in
this show I mean I feel like it's going to depend
on what comrad decides for his loyalty because
we've seen obviously he's conflicted uh with you
know his clandestine choices but uh he clearly
also wants to make sure his mom's happy so is he
a Mama's Boys you're gonna he's gonna go to the
good side that's pretty obvious his mom's really
bad she's pretty bad oh no wait he did see him so
um I could see the double blind where they
make him the villain like where she where he
has to prove himself to the clandestine I mean
it is conflicting for him I hope they really
play into the conflict for him yeah because in
the last episode that was something it was like
Mom's pet stopping her and then here I was
like oh he does he does have some sort of
You Raised Me perhaps she's rejecting me now
now I feel bad and I'm gonna take this out
on all women I did in the future well I do
think there is the chance to make him more
villainous uh the in this manner uh and I and
I think they'll go with the red dagger route
um but we'll see as far as love entrance
yeah fair enough fair enough so uh what's
everything that we learned in this episode
koi about um the clandestines well it's
interesting fail word was dropped the veil
word Greg was very confused by what is a
veil that's perfectly and sometimes it's not to
be capitalized so I was like what is the veil
serious
you see in weddings Greg there's a thing you
wear to keep your face hidden uh and then
sometimes the Gin use it to keep their culture
hidden no I I love that we're getting more and
more mythology in phase four and we've had uh
you know in the field of reads in Moon Knight
is very intriguing to see how you know that is
an element of uh other world and now we've got
this other you know through the portal Looking
Glass situation where we can apparently it's
kind of like the the smelly fart Theory like
you know some some people can smell uh certain
things and other creatures can't so like there
might be creatures that live amongst us that we
just don't have the the ability to witness and I
like the idea of using that for the supernatural
uh is this us how are we doing I'm trying to
make sure I make sure our reactions of prepping
footage in between here asked me a question
I was given a decent an answer with smelling
farts and you're over here it's not my job to
listen to you John interact with this guy yeah
that's all I'm asking but do you not think it's
an interesting thing that perhaps aliens walk
amongst us we just don't have the means to
witness them yeah it's it it reminds that
is an aspect and I know Doctor Who came up a lot
during Loki but that was something that reminded
me of Doctor Who I was like oh they're just
like out of phase with our reality right it's
like layered on top of it but the yeah the
molecules are just we just can't read them
differently displaced yeah yeah yeah and even
the the ultimate plan of like we want to tear
the Veil Down and just you know neuroform Earth
is the exactly you know it I'm trying to come
up with another nor pun right I really like the
Greg's got the dynamic with that I'm sorry guys
I really like the dynamic a lot with the mom and
the grandma and then watching how she's sort of
like because there was so much of resistance
towards like superheroes because that that's
something that I'm trying to pick up on the
mom as if does she believe in any of this
stuff right now like because from the flashback
with Aisha it seemed like she believed in in
some of the stuff that she was calling her the
saying that her the grandma was like the crazy
theories about things you know I just I was gonna
give you a little head Pat there through the veil
I'm really proud of you do you get what I'm
getting at because I'm saying we live in a
world of crazy superheroes and [__] so that
she should be she should believe in um some
of this like mystical stuff now right I really
also enjoyed the yes as well as the US wanting
to know how much she's aware and like what that
Aisha family history is I also really liked the
family Dynamic of three generations of who sees
the train what that connection is to the other
world all the the chaos of Greg opening times I
gotta do some [__] through the door Realms okay
let's get on track here all right it's too much
well some of us went through the mail some have
stayed all right frankly look I'm asking this
about the mom okay I'm gonna ask us about the
mom one more time because I feel like my question
was kind of rambling as I was multitasking perhaps
um it's just like the mom grabbed my
crap grandma or a mom who is the daughter
she the way she was talking with her mom about
saying like wild theories and stuff it seemed
like she's rejecting this but we saw in the
flashback when the mom the mom was with Aisha in
the flashback in episode three right I think she's
blocked it out personally my theory is the mom is
like this never happened I don't believe in it I
don't believe in magic this is not something our
family does right right because remember the the
bangle when it first appeared she was like nope
that's garbage like she very willingly separated
herself from it so I feel like she has like you
know but she's got to believe in some type of
level of magic now in the weird world that we
live in of blips and all that oh absolutely but
I imagine she doesn't think it's family I don't
think she accepts that it's happening like
this generational yeah when she talks about
the partition she likes like nope like she just is
is kind of uh compartmentalizing everything right
right um yeah that's true but either way I think
the mama is great I like the grandma performer
freaking amazing oh the acting in this is so good
and like every we met while lead and then within
two minutes I was like no like I was so invested
and I was worried for Forum uh also like new dude
like you know we met Cameron and automatically
Charming having a love triangle work cross world
is interesting like the fact that we're wondering
how that's going to go the fact that we're still
worried about him and still invested well Kareem's
definitely gonna go to New Jersey I hope so it's
kind of weird kind of weird it's gonna be great I
think maybe maybe it'll just be a show or Kamala
Khan just travels back and forth just hitting on
dude that would be cool I mean her mom just lets
her go back and forth I think that would actually
be cool however I think it's I like the way they
use the pilgrimage Motif idea as a part of this
like I expected them to go back you know and
and to visit the roots but but there's I don't
know like I think a nice parallel between like
the actual pilgrimage one might take and the
coming of age that this represents for Kamala
um and two I mean I I it makes me I love where
they ended off and that's part of what I've been
hoping for is like a real jump back into the real
past do a period piece moment dude something with
yeah a lot of extras a lot of real production
about you do some real history and I think think
if they settle there like I feel like the next
episode has to take place in the train station
during the partition at least for part of it
and I feel like that is an element that could
Elevate the magical newer World building because
I think that's what's missing from that is just
because this episode's moving really fast and it's
juggling on things that is the part that feels the
most perfunctory about this episode because it's
another magic land another magic group of people
in the Marvel Universe full of magic lands and
groups of people and I feel like if you really
so like really fuse that into the history and keep
going down that rabbit hole of this comes from a
cultural element even if it shares similarity
to Magic across the ocean I feel like that's
what could make that feel truly vital because
right now it's like it's cool and they got their
cool sanctum where they train and stuff but it
doesn't really feel as connected as you do when
you're transported to that train station to me
yeah it doesn't feel as lived in I think that's
what I meant earlier here to bring it back to my
justification I don't know why I was having issues
with some of the way the ex was because I feel
like it's just more information being thrown at
me and not seeing enough of really imbuing and
shown in that set you want to see it shown and
I think that's what episode five is going to do
show it instead of saying let's see about that
well and can I ask then because a lot of comic
book fans and people in the comments have have
grappled with the change in power or how the power
exists and where it comes from and why and I feel
like the strongest element through my eyes has
been when they really go through it's something
to do with your lineage and your culture I like
that change how do you feel about that so the
Inhumans are very much part of their culture it's
a rich history and all those things that make her
tied to that and I also think that her specific
power set is tied to puberty and body dysmorphia
and going through change and all those things so
when she stretches everything and and feels and
bigened but like ugly and wrong like their their
elements ever been like what is this this and then
she Embraces that that doesn't really get to be
an option with these Powers but they do get to
now play with the lineage because the nor so I'm
really curious how that all ties together because
now you can play with how it's ancestral how it is
tied to your history and like all those things I
don't know if they're going to bring I don't now
that we're this deep I don't think in humans are
tears and mystery that's coming to play but I do
think we might meet some family or someone in this
past that might make it feel more fleshed out and
more like it's a it's a lineage thing yeah well I
feel like with this show that it's it's really
more focused on the emotional stuff and more of
the like I think that they're exploring in a
way of like some generational trauma well the
comic's so family based uh I I've often said
that she to me is this generation Silver age
Spider-Man and the Silver age Spider-Man was
always so invested in his friends whether it
was like Harry and Mary Jane and Gwen like at
school or uh in college in that case or if it
was like the Uncle Ben Aunt May relationship where
like he was hiding stuff but also protecting his
little corner of New York and all those elements
feel like Miss Marvel's the modernized version
of that so I think they're doing a really good
job modernizing it even further by having the
medium of TV get you invested in the family as
much or more than the comic book like I love
her family like the cons are fascinating like
when the Grandma's on screen with the mom I'm
not looking for Kamala I'm like invested in their
relationship and and I think that's the strength
of Television versus comic books is they have
different things that they do better I don't
know that I'd be as invested in like a grandma
and mom team up comic whereas on this episode I
was like this is dope yeah how are you feeling
about uh the the villains the clandestines uh
they're not the villains of the comic book um
and that's not a problem but the clandestines
are a very obscure like miniseries so I'm really
curious like what elements tie into the little I
know about the clandestine that work for Miss
Marvel because it's it's kind of left field
as far as comic fans I mean in this episode
because I remember the last episode feeling
like that Aisha woman it's kind of scary but then
this time I was like these guys are kind of funny
if they do anything ominous in the next episode
or if we see any history of them where they do
something truly awful that like makes them scary
like it really felt like main Mentor guy for uh
Kareem was gonna die uh but other than that I was
like I don't know there's not intimidating anymore
yeah well it's always hard when you have like
multiple action set pieces where you're chasing
someone like you lose intimidation you're like
still gonna get you but at the end of the day
yeah yeah so like you know even though people
got stabbed it's like gonna get you the whole
episode yeah it's true uh so you know you're
a protagonist you're gonna be fun yeah yeah
she's got to be a young Avenger well until
you had the compounding tension of like oh
my God there's a big important life event that
this is intervening on in the previous episode
whereas here it's more like cool new setting
personal reason for being there but it's the
street chase and that's what was hard to have
at Hawkeye too was like you know a lot of times
it was chasing and like I enjoyed that bridge
scene in the car and everything else in Hawkeye
but that was like the first time I was like
okay we're not on foot with this mob like and
it's nice to mix it up but like when a show has
plot plot plot action plot same action it's hard
to not feel you're like well let's get back to
the yeah but the emotion might be the thing you
were talking about as well but the emotionality
yeah that thing that I've been Justified action
plot mysticism nor fails the emotionality of
uh just pretty much the character Expo rate
like I just think it's so cool that this show
is actually not a not shying away from that
like the grandma talking about what is like to
have this like senior ladies like lamenting of
and the idea that she's still trying to figure
out who she is yeah that's what I mean like having
this identity crisis over something that wasn't
her fault yeah at all it's just it's kind of the
world she's been born into and then seeing how
even Kamala in the states also has like issues
with this as well feeling like an outsider amongst
her family inside of her country's you know her
actual family's home food and stuff enjoyed that
identity moment and how it felt like it mirrored
a secret identity I really enjoyed her talking
about her identity and having dual identities and
like it's a show about a comic book like these
are Kamal economists Marvel or dual identities
and like that spelled out that way it was really
beautiful because the MCU doesn't have a lot of
secret identities like most everyone knows who
everyone is like capturing around like I'm Steve
Rogers uh so it's cool to have you know I've
been saying from the jump I think this is going
to lead to kamala's law all I think it's gonna
lead to the Young Avengers now we're talking
about secret identities but it not being in the
superhero sense but in like how you see yourself
and that's interesting I do think she's becoming
an obnoxiously good fighter a little too quick
hey Rey knew the force okay very quickly you make
a good point that's the best one in the most best
best Star Wars there it is Rise of Skywalker um
so yeah all right guys well overall overall great
like show man I'm vibing with this one I really
think it uh the setting being a character is rad
because that's a huge part of the comic I love
that Jersey City is such an important character
in the book and they've done Jersey City and
Pakistan Justice I think yeah and I think uh
if I'm gonna rank the guys I still put Bruno at
the top I mean come on guy in the chair Brian
good old Brian and then uh Cameron and the second
oh over my boy we just met him stop dude we just
met him and uh I don't know we'll scrape his
hair down though seemed the most generic of the
writing of them so far but he looked the coolest
of the three yeah great sword work uh knife work
for sure for sure all right guys we are done with
this video we need more mace in the next episode
we are ready to say goodbye uh do we have a patron
shout outs we can do more of the the name callouts
we can finish those I say we do it frog frog
You're such not a slog song High Donald Danny
the video game Glover Jacob Neptune what a way
to end June my angel Gabriel you've never heard
that in your life Mitchell Reed related to Riley
Reed nice NMB not my boba tea fan popso is running
from the Caps It Don't Mean a Thing If It Ain't
Got Alan Ling don't ever close the curtains on
Logan Burton Kiara come over here uh you thought
I was gonna say nightly Eric cons 39 we should
whine and dine I love me some coosey coosi Phil
either always getting lost like will Byers bear
in the garage that's recently been transformed
into an Adu Nick you would never be my ex if we
got together Don Juan Long John Longoria I would
never bail on Gail Ferguson Jaron Werner Brothers
Studio Pictures always get in the stiff Mr
Cliff Rodriguez Chris Bustin is the only one
I'd be trusting Master T you a real G call me a
homie bars John the grandest on any terrain seven
Go goat Akron yeah my oh my
is that Olivia Dell guy yes
I would love to get drunk within the funk
Lorenzo Baxter's always getting faster at
commenting on her Legend of Korra and telling us
every thought and opinion that Lorenzo thinks we
have wrong and is always quick to kind of get
into a bit of an argumentative she disagrees
with someone and we always appreciate the
comments and I'm always a tad nervous as to
what Lorenzo might comment because Lorenzo had
some strong opinions but when Lorenzo agrees
it feels good because and I feel like I did
something right I feel validated because Mommy
and Daddy never approved to me so when Lorenzo
approves of me I feel like I've been approved
of because it's a subconscious correlation
with my parental traumas thank you guys so
much for being part of our patreon page and
for pledging to our um this little specialty
here I gotta put a video up for you all I gotta
gets to find some some deleted footage here but
uh thank you all you guys rock you you rock
every one of you rocks you all are the best